[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui on arrive à trouver
quelque chose
ce 25 octobre
ça va sembler aux pacifistes et plus
autant de l'europe
y'a pas la cfdt non les écolos ils sont
pas un coût mais les écologistes n'ont
jamais l'effacer samedi de dessiner tout
ça fait une heure vous regarde
fonctionnez-vous l'échangé des idées
chacun fait son dessin en fonction des
autres vous décidez de quoi de la
couverture
vous cherchez la couverture c'est comme
ça qu'on fait la page des couvertures
auxquelles vous avez échappé au chic
comme ça comme ça qui font gouvernement
c'est votre conseil des ministres c'est
du brainstorming syndic dès dimanche
avec une couverture comme sa couverture
on va vendre je sais pas de me faire
dire ce que j'ai pas dis lui toi parce
que moi je dessine pour la manif de
samedi toi tu me décide pour la manif de
dimanche donc il suffit que les régions
étudiées de yachts comme ça pour cette
veine à des simples
[Musique]
avant il y avait des yeux quand il ya
des jeunes qui changera encore plus con
que nous qu'ils soient scolaires en plus
sur elle est particulièrement venimeux
mais les meilleurs dessins les dessins
que vous aimez vous c'est c'est ce
qu'ils sont mais d'une idée que ça très
très rapide ou ceux qui sont très chiadé
vient après réfléchir au cas il y en a
pas puisqu'on travaille ici comme ça sur
le tas on a chaud quoi j'ai découvert la
radio il ya un poids d'entre vous qui
apporte quand même le petit médecins
partant à l'avant cependant jamais tout
chemin de la maison et puis on garde
l'actualité toute fraîche au faisan on
veut découvrir les dernières nouvelles
quoi quoi c'est une réaction à chaud
mottin oui comment passez le lundi après
midi sur lui que ça soit une réaction
collective foule puis ça permet d'avoir
une masse de dessins aussi qu'ils sont
précieux l'intérieur du journal qu'on
réutilise mathieu weill a décidé
concernant ses parts dernier par exemple
et qui sont dessinés par novo
il ya une idée qui vient d'un d'un parmi
nous et qui est reprise par améliorée
par un autre os il ya d un brassage
quand même une émulation voilà qui est
sûr c'est que le premier public qu'on
essaie d'épater ses modèles si on arrive
à faire rire ici à cette table on se dit
qu'on a bien fait rire
il n'y a pas de raison que les experts
sont les coûts de couverture possible
dès 5h30 et chez vous quoi merde tous
les cas qui va arriver
[Musique]